[Music]
i was born and raised here in las vegas
i've always been an athlete i've tried
tons of sports softball and basketball
were my top two sports and
played softball at bishop gorman high
school here in las vegas
after that i got a scholarship to play
at the university of tulsa for four
years with my accident i had to your
whole life
changes and my whole life did and you
just learned how to be independent again
i was
i've always had that go-getter mindset i
was
if i won something i go get it and at
craig hospital they taught me how to be
independent and
with just daily things in my life and
then
from that when i got discharged i had to
learn more stuff and now i'm independent
driving
as an athlete they can train me like a
different way and coach me in different
ways so
we're doing feel good fridays every
friday in march
is 25 lift tickets and the great thing
about it is
uh it's a program where we can donate to
the hifize foundation
shelby you know like having her incident
here at lee canyon
um you know like really brings it home
to as far as like she's
she's an inspiration uh and wanting to
just you know
like just be competitive and and thrive